Clinical trials help scientists better understand
health and disease better. By volunteering
for a clinical trial you may be helping your
community, our society, and people in general.
Joining a clinical trial may not help
you, but it could help your grandmother,
your child, your neighbor, your friend,
or maybe even someone you’ve never met.
It is possible that, during a clinical
trial, you may receive treatment
that helps you. While It is also
possible that the treatment or
activity you do during a clinical
trial may not benefit you at all.
Before you volunteer for a clinical trial,
find out all risks and benefits associated with
participating in the trial so that you have all
the facts before making a decision. Ask questions.
What is being studied?
What is the purpose of the clinical trial?
How long will the trial last?
How many study visits will I have to attend?
What kinds of tests or
procedures will be preformed?
Blood tests or physical
examinations are just an example.
Will I be able to take my regular
medicines during the clinical trial?
What are the possible risks and benefits
of participating in the clinical trial? And
How will the results of the
clinical trial be shared with me?
When you have as much information
as possible about a clinical trial,
you’ll feel much more confident
about the decision you make.
Before you sign up for a clinical trial,
ask the people who are conducting the
trial to answer all of your questions. And
remember that you may stop participating
in the clinical trial at any time,
even after the study has started.